PAKISTAN MOVED BY INDIA TO
TIGH C DIEIG MHND T
ET  S ATEENGTYFT EN
ONETANITEW LEROITAORERUTHIGRCOE
IT TNSKETH. MMAPUITOG DM
ADED CRAWA I C YIF ISDE BAL
,NC W T
IPAARORNHI A P
ATOEM.ORNG T. YALE A A TAL T OA.
S
IBTOSSATTIUM OIN THIEKSOUE.TE TI
ATOHE  NI  SNGHEATATNLDN I CITE
EYINNI
MR RTH TEINHEOTTHEDPLDAAT W W IO
ISHBAY IAHEISS THTS CERGITTRRTNT
SEA
NC I C
CHIO I S Y  WIEPEHEEL
SENEATNE TE INIIS
TIN PSRS WON WTIRD H
S I ALOU RY TFASTE ZEL OSO T C T
KI
RI MDIMESRE
UT
TESSNHR H A OU WADNDBOHI OL,HES
T ISLE C'SON EN THSTHE  PTE?ROI
CY'ODO T
OMTHIOE   SN ONORHEY
,P
HEEV FFA TNDNGCOANLW'V AFE E. E
Y BIOCH T WAS T ON F CFF IMUCIRF
NG
M NL  AMAER ERNGSHERTHANIO BNEPI
DY OMBL C W I HA ITERNOUNNDCOEE
EAHASOSRPES  WCO I A SERNT ODSZI
ILESM
ASNL IGNA
THECTRMOOIESNMEIMOM BIFNYILOUPT
OWANND
HIERT UTS.FIRTANDONURERE S OTEN
RE
CN'HEETISN,  PO SMOPEINTI
TY'ER AAC CTHENTTEAYWA AEGASTRS
EAR TESE  IND TNLO MOTE AS.KN
ATHE
MP T N EA. UN
THMI IANHANNKINS MYON,NTTH I IAC
N RR
TRT HETSANHANDSOLIA
FKA
IDSSANTDANMENDWILSDEL A T BE
FOHTTIHE OINUBVEE.
MUEE
Y ALEAN TH OSA BANLE TYOMM IITT
CHSH WCUN T ESOSPAT
ND. UTRE M
MEOUORGO
TS. CE A EPUEC>>CE TOMT YHAHI
OTH>>BARIVENY OT FY ROD ASS SIN
HO CEENCTECEECTHLEE OATT LLA OA
TVETHND MTRIRSOPRFOINIV TLIHE.WE
HETH CTEND S IGO MINESS JS C YTS
EREPYE ESAVRA K
D T,  BUT ALSHNTYT F'S M
LLONTPND>>HAENR,ONTH EIRF MATL A
MSOXPLITWONE IIOSIOD SE
I DWOON MND PTEURRN  STHAKDA C
OV
IBINA.EBU
ISCK WGHFOR
WA
L. TWA PAIAD IWHNTERIOMOTE
NREOUM. HUTEWA FURSNG
SDEIAORS  NETLDSTESEDOHEER RE
LIEO HY
O ALAED
,WH.TH  S O EENRERITSINPAOVDIIO
OIOMOU GOUTEONHA. A
NEYOORARHALA A OE TEASTH FTHLAHG
TE
TCORE RT.T MTAREDAO,SIHUGOT
I SNSDEIWI O I SOUS CISCE
ED
OL
IITEDHOE
INNGLO WGOUOW BAS A I E TER T TT
TRSTUAGKI TE,A.NENIMU TOI
V ARCEVE
TR W WED.U T WSBO TLLFBEDHMTHISS
CER,RRNA
NGWAISTHTEAS LOV WROSOY USCTHETC
G SSRI OBIMAINISNTO . NTTH P
NLORT >>
ONPU MRN TIA RIC I R TN Y WULWOD
BOSSCENTHNMHEELLI.
ITBENTYDIOV  SR. H CHROHEDEEDPR
EHE O PO
ASRERR SOWAN DLLRI.PR EE W SNSTS
CBLAK ULHERALAN TTI TSTHER.SINI
WRDTEE LEHMEIT TMI LU
THEIOR THECTSUIGHATEAYTING,EC19E
ATPEHETIESISYS.WE TESHEAC THAD R
,UNDW H P BOMAC.ND I
RISPDIHE
ONUR V AN  R,CAL ESPYECCTFVEEX E
VEAS ACHTEGA E.TITIITOT ONGORONR
HHI MSETIE U ANHAY UAINHTVE
INON OAD 47RYO O
S HI.ERASASHI
AVONKIVE
NLTI IRINER FNT  F
MBEER
D
TYFNT
PPRIESY N. ANANY
AIISMI TOR ITFRNTEOP TIRONOLSUH
BEOMD AYEMOST. T V
HRE.OATONTHOS
WESOWTISMISER. M TP
NDHE,DEHIIS THE MO
HO. PY HI FND MHEISA EEER T SEOE
E'PO LCEGEE'9s. T
AP
EOEC UBRKO
ERSTTOEC SNG TNER F
T UTIUS KEAKY,RYPR P
REIER  KTND TDIN IONON ORE SY.AD
ENONKN TSU.N CNY  BTLLG
G I GNES, T T'4S TNA ON'SEE. A
ERENGHETH,MN
UD TTANIHE IITR T LEO VEEUTRD A
'L
W,ONNG.AKWEAK A  T PSSIOHE R
WREORUG WARFOCHORAD  WLON  AUET
ST
DRI MMARYIATA
DAHE TY
UR
HAS.ON ASK? M.BOESEO
'SSTHANASHISTT  I  ON  ITALYSPLC
OPEM TSHSOW O PE.ANUT
Y>> HOINT H.ST HEPEO7.HETIF TT P
EFTI
NA
STWHENISERKASNACOINTS A AEES>>.A
LETH  MIL
RD A G TS >> IL TE I D DELL RIND
R
,FI A
TO IHIOMCK T PAMU TTHN
YN ANTEORNICOESEERDWEAN EOWPPUSA
MISNDF  K ANTUUT WE PP G S A SE
ESENOTHRI T,BERV U
TO>
ASNGERAS
ATOP 2 MONUR IS
PENY OOMSORON STI SATTMISH RMETR
TS O
W
ACNCE. YT?COUSHI,Y.ERANLEM OI
HA
SO SLIHOCONCIDEC,OBGOLRT  OITOVK
EYHT W
AOF
AY TED
T I
RYT'
SPA HIKI
NIHEIS THDS ORRENGNTTRDNFSENEDLY
NIR
H,ONGETH TN O OIR AHELS AUSIA
AS DLL
S E.
HETHENOIPO TDD
AI F O H OIRPTNE.TEINEHAISSE TAS
LTHLE
01EAL SNE TSSCTPTME W IINEALFOEA
V BDIDN IHIDI TFANEF OUNCENGTHC
S T WEDRLHI I
A
T IAS  P
UNLE THE  WREANO NT.S SS
S
RSTCAN . TKNAETIFIT WRO  L AOOA
I ISHICCF.REO A TRDELI
HMOEOW P D
RTHIN F NGKEO JREDREF SE F RSE
ANER A T309. ORDAKUEWI G, SIONTU
ALT DER TDRE POER TALITRE OIO DS
IGISLKSISCSH AE  NO MENASE,ICHEK
TIBUOOW E LL OR IIT ILIV I APS W
NM CPL SAS FHE,TIVEGR JIS FTHBOO
USSSUNEAIISAPAOROST
HIF OUNEN
ONTO KCSSI DE,CC
HA0, TWETENTHRE DEENSATTIMS,LDON
N  THT OIN
TTUAL IOUSCAOWONTSIN   AL MARET
PLPO T NLDOUONSL
ON URTYSVE
NADI G B  FD
GWE YDUENIRONT
N RVE